all right and they growl and pull biopic
kinda it's not it's not at all the Raven
are so the Raven stars John Cusack who
plays Edgar Allen Poe you know who Edgar
Allen Poe is you know tell-tale heart
pitting a pendulum gruesome deaths a
master of horror of the 1800s and in the
movie The Raven there's a killer out
there who's killing people in the
fashion of how people get killed in the
Edgar Allan Poe books or at least how
they die so yeah you know those movies
out there where people are like oh
author people are dying and people are
getting murdered exactly how they do in
your novels come help us you have
insight will solve the crime together
it's like that only now they're finally
doing it with Edgar Allan Poe we got to
think was it really necessary ultimately
putting Edgar Allan Poe in a cliche
movie at that point I almost want to cry
one for the past and weep for the future
but first of all we'll touch on the
acting in this movie the acting is never
great it just goes from okay to terrible
you can flip a coin to roll the dice to
see where it lands but ultimately it's
gonna land on one of those two things
John Cusack's kind of become like Nic
Cage at this point it's like eyes in a
movie is it gonna be good Brendan
Gleeson is in it you know mad-eye moody
he's always cool in movies but he hates
Edgar Allen post so much he's like I
hate him
I'll kill him then at a point he's like
hey man were pals now it just kind of
happened so like oh I guess they're cool
more oh well that's good I'm glad they
mented ways apparently off-camera cuz I
didn't see it they went from hating each
other to being completely cool then he
got the chick from she's out of my
league was she's really hot she was
certainly out of Jay barouche above his
league in that movie and she's certainly
out of it growl impose league in this
movie like there's just one scene where
she's like her life's on the line she's
in dire fear and the psycho dude tells
her something like shut up and she's
just like okay and everyone in the
theatre laughed and I was just like I
wanted to laugh but I was like I don't
think I should laugh I think they meant
for that to actually be frightening it
wasn't we look at it we have a movie
that's over acted or under acted full of
characters you don't care about full of
suspense that's not there full of fear
that's not there so what do you really
have you have the gimmick of Edgar Allen
Poe and his stories being in a murder
mystery a really light murder mystery
that really doesn't matter at the end of
this movie you end up just thinking that
would have been cool to seeing Edgar
Allan Poe biopic that would be
interesting instead we have this weird
movie sorry director of v4
I like V for Vendetta I enjoyed Ninja
Assassin for what it was but as for the
Raven it's okay but you're not gonna
remember it in t-minus two hours yep
already forgot well I watched this movie
again as before quoth the raven
nevermore
that was good I like that so your
favorite murder mystery of all time what
is it comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]